plein oui ce soir on attend avant tout
des nouvelles de gaston defferre le
député maire de marseille qui a été
hospitalisé cette nuit et qui est dans
un état préoccupant
d'ailleurs l'ancien premier ministre
laurent fabius est sur place et nous
appelons je crois tout de suite la
station du reste la fin d'un règne ou
d'une grande carrière politique c'est la
question que je pose à l'un de mes
confrères en direct de marseille je me
tourne vers le mur d'image je crois que
c'est dominique bonnot qui est avec nous
depuis le plateau de fr3 marseille
dominique c'est à vous oui il est un peu
difficile de parler de la fin d'un règne
quand une personne est dans le coma dans
le coma grave si du moins ce qui ressort
de l'état de santé du communiqué d'êta
de santé de gaston defferre qui a été
dans la lecture nous a été faite vers
17h30 un communiqué qui précise une
diminution de l'activité cérébrale et
des doubles des troubles du rythme
cardiaque de gaston defferre depuis ce
matin le maire de marseille est en fait
dans un état excessivement critique sans
connaissance il a été admis à l'hôpital
de la timone vers 5 heures du matin
après un malaise survenu à son domicile
vers 2 heures du matin gaston defferre
sortait d'une réunion harassante une
réunion politique au sein du parti
socialiste section des bouches du rhône
il avait été mis en minorité par liste
de michel peser et 7 défaites
visiblement l'avait affecté certains
observateurs ont noté même qu'il était
très rigide seule dans son appartement
donc le maire de marseille a juste eu le
temps de téléphoner à son médecin
traitant avant de perdre connaissance et
de heurter la tête la première le coin
d'une table ce n'est que trois heures
plus tard que gaston defferre a été
hospitalisé mais il avait perdu beaucoup
de sang diagnostic des médecins
traumatisme crânien graves et
hémorragies externe à l'hôpital de la
timone d'attentes se poursuit donc
le prochain communiqué médical est prévu
vers 21h30
à moins que en attendant à son chevet
des sig diverses personnalités dont vous
l'avez dit laurent fabius venu
spécialement de paris et qui restait
plus de trois heures dans l'antichambre
de gaston defferre dominique bonnot je
vous remercie